being a man might seem like a scary  thing but it's simpler than you think  here's a couple tips a man knows how to  present himself always against the grain  and always looks great in a mustache a  man knows how to work with his hands  sawdust is man glitter perfect and  always have the right tool for the job  just say if you want harder Theodore a  man practices regular introspection  reading philosophical Maxim's and when  you stare long into an abyss the abyss  also stares into you a man knows how to  cry have to allow yourself to feel  thank you see you doing a man knows how  to order a drink barkeep pour me a  cookie duster extra marshmallows a man  knows how to dance a man knows how to  impart his wisdom perfect remember  safety first  ouchy thank you give in to the power of  the music  being a man isn't hard and it should  come naturally yeah bad good down there  perfect